[Music]
you get to a point where you're
auditioning for a role and it's just
like it's
it's a piece of cake like you walk in i
mean now it's got to get to a point
where you walk in and you don't get that
nervous i mean i don't know auditioning
it never gets easier really but
especially when you're first starting
out you know it's like you have no idea
what you're doing how old were you when
you first started i i'm probably like 19
19. so it's been you know i've been
getting i've been doing this for like
eight years now but
still it's still a tough tough time
always going in but when you're first
starting out you don't know what you're
doing you haven't developed
relationships with any of these casting
directors and
i you know one of my very first
auditions ever um
i went in the audition itself it went
fine
and then the casting director she says
to me um can you slate for me real quick
so to slate basically means just to look
into the camera and say your name simple
as that it gives them a marker so when
they're looking and editing they see
okay all right this is dave franco 100
so at the time i i wasn't aware of the
terminology
so i i you know i was like i'm so sorry
what was that just one more time
and so she's like oh just just slate for
me real quick so
what i hear is can you sleep for me real
quick
so i'm like all right
so i get comfortable
and she's like no i was like what
so we have a good laugh and you know as
a little bit later when i'm leaving she
starts cracking up again and she's like
i can't imagine what was going through
your head when you thought i asked you
to sleep but i'm like i don't know you
tell me to do it i'm going to do it i
want a job
[Laughter]
i may have snored may or may not have
snored yeah how good was your sleeping
was it like that kind of sleeping was it
this kind of sleep literally i think i
popped my arms out like this yeah i'm
going to sleep now
it was awful that's funny um all right
we have uh let's talk about warm bodies
yeah we have a clip for the movie but
very unusual premise for this film sure
yeah it's um you know it's a
human girl who falls in love with a
zombie
and
all right hear me out
no i like it
you know it's it's it's funny it works
on a bunch of different levels but it's
just when you when you first hear the
pitch of course i'm sorry as someone
who's been dead for a while totally i'm
with you girl's like he's hot
it's um it's one of these movies yes on
paper it's it sounds sounds a little
strange but you throw in a director like
jonathan levine who did this movie
called the wackness and then this movie
5050. so i've been a huge fan of him
and he's one of these guys who
i i want to make my own films one day
you know with these funnier dive movies
it's like on a smaller scale and i want
to make my own films and i just want to
be around these guys that i've admired
and i just want to just see his process
and how he works with actors and he
really did make it unique you know it's
really funny too it's got actors like
rob cordrey yes who's just hilarious and
it's awesome i'm really proud of it i'm
barely in the movie but
i'm here promoting it i love it yeah
i gotta say
i've been doing this a long time i've
never heard someone say i'm barely in
the mood i don't know
so if you're like me see the movie
cause i'm not in it
that's fantastic now you like this go
and see that but you won't see this
again first first late night talk show
up here
firstly appearance i love it uh all
right what do we need to know for this
scene are you at least in this scene i
hope so
i have money to choose from but
uh this scene as far as i know
i hope you're not in the scene that
would be so great
please don't be in this scene please
please don't even be the right movie
please that would be so great um so
let's hope that it's the scene where uh
it's a it's a group of soldiers going
out to get medicine to bring back to
their camp and there are zombies looming
nearby
i don't even think that all right let's
take a look
did you hear that
i did
we should fail oh hey we can't just bail
we have orders
do you have any idea how much medicine
the city goes through a month we need
pharma salvage to survive we can't just
abandon her i'm just like my dad
thank you yeah it wasn't a compliment
oh here guys
take some pros at maybe that'll cheer
you up
i told you i heard something
perry
we have orders jules
there's nothing anyway
you're being paranoid okay
[Applause]